and finally new rule if authorities in
New York are going to continue their
crackdown on Time Square psychics an
industry that sucks millions of dollars
out of gullible people with the vague
promise of a better life they have to
answer one question how is religion
different all right all right don't
worry
don't worry I'm gonna let you answer
that one tonight because tonight folks
is not about religion it's about
political religion and about how
gullible people can be psychics you know
are not really clairvoyance they're con
artists who know how to read subtle
behavioral clues like they might
correctly guess that you're single and
lonely if they go to read your palm and
your dick isn't
and although although fortune-telling is
actually protected by the First
Amendment
it does raise a moral question best
expressed by a New York detective who
was on the case and who asked is it okay
to rob stupid people send your answers
to Glenn Beck tell me your PIN number
dot-com but you know what happened in
New York is the psychics got so greedy
it became impossible to ignore one
psychic took this guy for over 700,000
dollars by telling him that she could
deliver to him the woman he loved even
though that woman did not love him why
didn't she love him because of evil
spirits the kind psychics know how to
get rid of oh and also one other thing
at one point she died but not a problem
said the psychic who told the guy he
could still be with her she'd just be in
a different body at this point the guy
went to the police and said he was
suspicious yeah but he kept giving the
psychic more money this is what experts
call the sunk cost fallacy which means
the more you sink money into something
the more you have to believe it even in
spite of new evidence that you know
she's dead Jim even after the psychic
was proven completely wrong the sucker
still had faith in her which brings me
to the Republican Party
now I'm not saying that Republicans are
like psychics cuz psychics are right
some time whereas trickle-down economics
has never been right and yet Republican
voters keep buying into it even though
that girlfriend has been dead since the
80s and speaking of dead since the 80s
you may have noticed that Dick Cheney
was back in the news last week Dick
Cheney was back in the news that's why
you saw the sky turned gray and all
those crows gathering on the jungle gym
yes dick was also making predictions
about Obama's Iran deal even though
about Iraq he had said there is no doubt
Saddam has weapons of mass destruction
and we will be greeted as liberators you
have to give it to Republicans they have
big balls they're just not crystal ball
you think at some point Meet the Press
would say let's stop booking Dick Cheney
and get someone more credible like a bag
of fortune cookies it's invading Iraq a
good idea better to press shirt than to
press look there I just said just four
trillion dollars I mean it goes on and
on during the last election Mitt Romney
said if President Obama is re-elected
you will not be able to get a job but
unemployment is now lower than it ever
was under Reagan its Romney who can't
get a job mitt also said if we bailed
out the car companies you can kiss the
American automotive industry goodbye but
we did bail them out that it's doing
better than ever
Donald Trump said Obamacare would be a
job killer but it didn't kill jobs it
didn't result in death panels
it didn't bankrupt the states it didn't
bankrupt the nation
it didn't bankrupt Medicare it didn't
bankrupt the insurance industry here's
what actually happened the insurance
companies got richer some black kids got
inhalers and John Boehner had to pay
more taxes on his tan
or how about Newt Gingrich in 2012
saying if you want $10 a gallon gasoline
Barack Obama should be your candidate or
the NRA president saying a reelected
Obama would erase the Second Amendment
from the Bill of Rights a Rick Santorum
warning that if gay marriage became the
law of the land our country will fall
you know for a party that's so anti-gay
they sure pull a lot of stuff out of
there
you